good evening people um even how are you guys doing all right my name is archa Sharma I'm a PhD student at Stanford and I'm very very excited to talk about post training generally speaking for large language models and I hope you guys are ready to learn some stuff because this has been one of the last few years in machine learning have been very very exciting uh with the Advent of large language model CH GPD and everything to that extent and hopefully after today's lecture you will be more comfortable
understanding how we go from pre-train Models to models like CH GPD and we'll take a whole journey through prompting instruction fine tuning and DP and rlf so let's get started all right so something that has been very fundamental to our entire field is this idea of scaling loss and models are increasingly becoming larger and larger and they're expanding more and more compute so this is a graph of models starting all the way back in 1950s to somewhere around these are still this is an outdated graph so like this shows up
to 10 to^ 24 flops or floating Point operations that go into pre-training these models but the number is well above 10 to^ 26 now but you can see the graph and the way it's trending and more more and more compute requires more and more data because you need to train on something meaningful and this is roughly the trend on the amount of language tokens that are going into the language models in pre-training and again this plot is outdated does anybody want to guess like we're in 2024 2022 we were at 1.4 trillion tokens or
words roughly speaking in language model pre-training do does anyone want to guess like where we are in 2024 that's a pretty good guess yeah so we're close to 15 trillion tokens um recent llama 3 models were roughly trained on 15 trillion tokens so yeah just just for a second appreciate that these are a lot of words uh this is not yeah I don't I don't think anybody of us listens to like trillions of tokens in our lifetime so this is where we are right now and I hope you guys were here for the pre-
pre-training lectures cool um so what do we do so like I mean broadly speaking we are really just learning to predict text tokens or language tokens but what do we learn in the process of pre-training why is why are people spending so much money so much compute because these Compu and tokens take dollars to do and we're we're on the order spending hundreds of millions of dollars on these runs so why are we doing this and this is basically a recall from whatever you have probably learned till now but we're learning
things like oh we are learning knowledge Stanford University is located in Santa clar California or wherever you want to like say you're learning syntax you're learning semantics of the sentences these are things that you would expect to learn when you're training on language data broadly you're probably learning a lot about different languages as well so like depending on your text Data distribution you're learning a lot of things but the models we interact with are very intelligent so where is
that coming from like I mean just simply learning about very factual things and it's a very simple loss function we're optimizing and where is that Intelligence coming from and this perhaps is the interesting bit recently like people have like started accumulating evidence for that like when you optimize the next token prediction losses you're not just learning about syntax you're not just learning knowledge but you're starting to like form models of Agents beliefs and actions as well so how do we know
this again a lot of this is speculative evidence but it's mayy to like form an understanding that the losses we're optimizing are not just about the data fitting the data but you start learning something maybe more meaningful as well um for example like I mean in this specific case um we change the last sentence and the prediction of the text or the next Tex that that is predicted changes as well so here it starts with Pat watch as a demonstration of a bowling ball and the leaf being dropped
at the same time pat who is a physicist predicts that the bowling ball and the leaf will land at the same rate we all know Gravity the way it works but when you L change the last sentence to Pat who has never seen this demonstration before Pat predicts that bowling ball will fall to the ground first maybe somebody who's never seen this experiment before might intuitively believe that correct so like I mean the language model was able to predict this so how do you predict this you have to have some notion of understanding of how
humans work to even be able to predict this and that's maybe like something that is not obvious with You're simply optimizing to predict the text similarly like I mean these kind of examples are we're going to run through some examples to like sort of communicate that when you're pre-training these models you're learning much more than just language tokens and so on you're also learning about math like you're able to understand what a graph of a circle means and what the center is and where
how to like understand equations probably my favorite example something I use pretty much every day is you're learning how to write code so I don't know how many of you have interacted with co-pilot before but if you have like you probably know like if you write down a few commands write down a function template it will automatically complete code for you so again it's not perfect but it has to have some deeper understanding of what your intent is for something like that to emerge and similarly we have examples
from medicine as well I don't know about you guys but like whenever I have some issue I probably go to chat gbd or Claude or something to that effect and ask them a diagnosis for those things as well um I don't recommend that uh please don't take medical advice from me but yeah so broadly like the way we're seeing language models at this point is that like they're sort of emerging as this general purpose multitask assistance and it's very strange right like I mean we started off with text
token prediction and we're reaching the stage where it can like sort of rely to them on them to do many many different things so how are we getting there and I'm sure you all are aware of like what these models are so yeah so today's lecture is largely going to be about how do we go from something Stanford University is located this very simple pretraining task a very simple procedure well it's more complicated but in abstract terms it's not very complicated to like something as
powerful as CH GPD cool so um I recommend you guys stopping me asking me a lot of questions because this is a there's a lot of fun examples and a lot of fun techniques so like I I want you guys to like learn everything about here so the overall plan is we're going to talk about zero shot and few shot in context learning um next we're going to follow up with instruction fine-tuning and then we're going to talk about optimizing for preferences and this is where roughly things are right
now in the industry and when we're going to talk about what's next what the limitations are and how do we move from here cool so we're going to start off with zero shot INF fusure in context learning um broad we're going to take an example example of GPT or the generative pre-train Transformer and this is a whole series of models that started off in roughly 2018 and like up to 2020 they were building GPD gpd2 gbd3 so we're going to start off with this example and yes so it's a decoder only model that is
trained on roughly 4.6 GB of text and it has 12 layers of Transformers layers and it's trained with the next token prediction loss and the first model obviously was not extremely good but it started showing that like hey like this technique for pre-training can be very effective for general purpose tasks and we're going to see some examples um for example like I mean here it's able to do the task for entainment and okay um yeah and gbd1 itself was not very strong as a model so like but they took
the same recipe and like I mean tried to like increase the model size so they went from 117 million parameters to about 1.5 billion parameters and we're now scaling up the data alongside as well so we went from 4 gabt of data to approximately 40 gab of data and pre-training is a whole different like melting part of techniques and there's a lot that goes into it but like roughly for example here they filter data by the number of upwards on the redit data and yeah so this is roughly where
we are and I think one of the things that started emerging with gpd2 is zero shot learning and what do we mean by zero shot learning um conventionally in the field like when we pre-train models there was the idea that you take a few examples you update the model um and then you are able to adapt to a specific task but as you pre-train on more and more data and more and more tasks you sort of start seeing this phenomena where they're able to do the task basically zero short they're shown no examples of how to do the task
and you can start thinking of oh how you can do it summarization you can follow some instructions you can do maybe a little bit of math as well so this is where the idea of zero shot learning started to emerge yeah so how do we do zero shot learning or task specific learning from these pre-trained models really the idea is that we have to be creative here we know that these are text prediction models if you put in a text they will complete whatever follows so if we can sort of course these models into
completing the task we care about maybe it's question answering we can so start getting them to solve tasks here so for example if you want to ask questions about Tom Brady you sort of set it up you sort put information about Tom Brady and then you put a question that you wanted to answer and then it will autocomplete in some sense so this is one early perspective on these models these are very Advanced autocomplete models and similarly if you want to figure out like which answer is true or which is not
something that is very useful to measure is log probabilities so for example we want to figure out what is the word it refering to here in this sentence the cat couldn't fit into the Hat because it was too big um what we can do is we can take the sentence replace it with either the cat or either the hat and then you can measure the probability of which Mo which one does the model think is higher and you can sort of get the idea what the reference here is so none of this is like in the training data it's simply learning to
predict text but you can start seeing how like we can leverage these models to do other tasks as well be besides prediction so this is just more evidence about like how gpd2 no task specific fine-tuning no task specific training it simply is learning to predict text and it's establishes the state-of-the-art on many many different tasks simply by scaling up the model parameters and scaling up the amount of data it's stained on so this is a fun example so if you want to do summarization for data or like you
have a news article that you want to summarize so how do you get a zero shot model to do it this answer is you put the document into the context and you simply put tldr in front of it now like I mean if most of the data on internet whenever you see tldr you'll naturally summarize it so yeah you can get zero shot performance and summarization here as well and again this is not trained to do something summarization in any specific way and it's still doing really well simply because of its pre-training
data so yeah um I think gp22 tldr is somewhere there and like some of the very Tas specific train models are um like and I think you will see the trend with again if you were Alec Radford or somebody like I mean you see like these cool things emerging your next step would obviously be I'm going to scale this up a little more I'm going to make an even bigger model I'm going to train it even more data and we'll see how things go right so that's how we got gbd3 uh we went from 1.5 billion
parameters to 175 billion parameters we are well over like 40 GB of data to 600 gbt of data of course like now we're in like terabytes of data and text is a very compressed representation so like terabytes of data is a lot um and you know we we talked about zero shot learning the cool thing that emerged in gbd3 is like go ahead like used before the passage right no you typically put the passage uh if youve like interacted with Reddit or something like that typically somebody will write an entire post and then end with TLD drr
here's a summary of the thing too long didn't read or if you have used opposite comes first oh yeah there are situations where it also comes first but um one reason is that these are like decoder only models so like they are often these are causal attention models so the typically need to see the context before yeah understand I'm just curious like from my experience the comes first then how is it the okay um there's probably a lot of data where the tldr comes first but there's probably a lot of data where
tldr comes after as well cool so we saw Zero shot learning emerging in gpd2 few shot learning maybe seem slightly easier but like this is where things started getting really funny is that like you're starting to beat state-ofthe-art simply by just putting examples in context so yeah what does f shot learning mean here what is what are we talking about um as I mentioned like the typical idea here is is that like you want to solve translation so you would put some examples of translation into
context and you know this is a correction task here or maybe you want interested in Translation and no gradient updates no learning in any conventional sense whatso ever you put a few examples in and that's it like I mean you know how to solve the task isn't that like crazy like you're bu you guys did the assignment on translation right so but this is what the modern NLP looks like so yeah um you put in some examples and you have the entire system and this is where things got really interesting is
that all these task specific models that were created to like be really really good at translation or really good at summarization you can just put let's look at this graph so we start with a zero shot performance of this in a similar fashion that I described earlier and you start somewhere there you put one example in of translation from English to French you get to somewhere like already at a fine level few examples in you're already starting to like be close to the state-ofthe-art models wait but in that gra the state of
theart is really high isn't it uh find your Inver of the bird Plus+ here I think is like the one I'm referring to find your of the like which is trained exclusively on a lot of um translation data might be like slightly better yes um and I think that's the relevant comparison here is the in context learning starts to emerge at scale so and this is I think like the key point is that this some of this is contested just to be very upfront but like there's this idea of emergence of this property as you train on more
Computing and more scale um there's more recent research which suggest that if we plot the access correctly it feels less emergent but the general idea is as you increase the number of parameters and increase the number of compute that is going into the models the ability to just go from a few examples to really strong performance is very compelling cool um and yeah I think as I explained earlier the general idea is that this is very different from the conventional idea of fine tuning that we typically go
for instead of like iterating over examples putting it into context and doing gradient updates we are actually just going for few short promting we're going to put in few examples and that's going to give us the system um yes I mean the exact details roughly can depend on the prom template that you use but typically you would just put examples so like c order and put these examples and then whatever your task is you can just let the model complete from there because it can infer the task
um based on the examples you've given any other questions cool so yeah like I mean we have gotten from zero shot prompting and like we've seen seeing that F shot prompting is becoming really competitive with good models but there's still limitations to this like I mean you cannot solve every task that you see here and particularly like things that involve like richer multi-step reasoning is something that actually can be pretty challenging and just to be fair human struggle at these
tasks as well so things like addition and so on like these are these are probably like still still hard to do like when you keep increasing the number of digits but one thing that you have to start being creative with I alluded to this earlier is that you can get these models to do the task if you're creative in how you prompt the model and this is what we're going to see next um so this technique called Chain of Thought prompting emerged here and the idea that we have explored thus far
is that we put in examples of the kind of tasks we want to do and we expect the model to zero shot learn what the task is and go from there um the idea is that like instead of just showing what the task is you show them examples where they reason through the task so they're not just learning to do the task but also learning how the reasoning is working so in this example initially we started with like we have to solve a simple math problem and we are just shown exactly the answer answer directly
instead of doing that and if you do that directly you'll observe that the model gets the answer wrong instead of that what if you show model how to reason about the task show it a chain of thought and include that in the prompt as well and then you ask at a new question the idea is that now the model is not just going to Output an answer it's going to reason about the task and it's going to do actually a lot better and this has been shown to be very effective um Chain of Thought is also as you can
see like I mean it's again something that improves a lot with model scale it's not just um yeah um but what you can probably start seeing is like it's nearly better than supervised best models here so power models roughly were about 5 40 billion parameters and simply with this Chain of Thought kind of a skill you're already like beating state of the art cool um so yeah so I showed you examples of Chain of Thought reasoning to to this point where you go through a reasoning chain but you can be even slightly
smarter than that you might not even need to show them any examples you just need to trick them into thinking about what to do next um so yeah this s this idea emerged in this paper called where you let's think step by step where instead of even showing an example you just start your answer with let's think step by step and that's it like I mean the model will start reasoning about the answer itself instead of just like autoc completing to an answer and you get something like this so maybe you don't even need to show any
examples like you can probably induce the reasoning Behavior through zero shot Behavior as well and again um what the final numbers look like is like compared to zero shot performance that we got from essentially autoc comp completing this zero shot Chain of Thought substantially improves the performance so you go from like 17.7 to 78.7 it's still worse than still putting like examples of reasoning and multi-shot few shot Chain of Thought as well but you can see like how much it improves the
performance simply by asking you to let's think by step by step and maybe this is like a lesson that interacting with these models is like when you interact with these models you might not get the exact desired behavior from these models up front but often like these models are capable of doing the behavior that you might want and often you have to think about how to induce that behavior such that and the right way to think perhaps is like what is the pre-training data what is the data on the internet it might have seen which
induces a similar Behavior to the kind I want and you probably want to like think about that and then induce these kinds of behaviors from those models and yeah like I mean um you know we we hand designed some of these prompts you can also like get an llm to design these prompts as well there's like recursive self-improving ideas here um that happen and you can bump up the performance a little bit more cool so what we have seen so far is that as models get stronger and stronger you can start forcing them to do your
task zero shot or with few short examples and you can trick them into thinking what task you want them to solve but the downside is that there's only so much you can fit into context this might not be very true anymore models like becoming increasingly larger context but it's still somewhat unsatisfactory to think you have to trick the model into doing your task rather than like it just doing the task you wanted to do and potentially like I mean going forward like you probably still want to fine
tune these models for more and more complex tasks and that's where we're going to go forward in this um next section we're going to cover is instruction fine tuning and the general idea we have right now is that as we talked about pre-training is not about assisting users it is about predicting the next token now you can trick it into assisting users and uh following the instruction you wanted to but in general that's not what it retrained it for and this is an example of where if you ask
GPD 3 pretty strong model to explain like moon landing to a six-year-old in a few sentences and it will follow up with more questions about what a 60-year-old might want this is not what you wanted the model to do right so the general term that people use these days is that they're not aligned with user intent and the next sections that we're going to cover are going to talk about how to align it with the user intent so that they don't have to trick the model into whatever uh we wanted to
do and this is a kind of like desired completion we want at the end of instruction tuning um and yeah how do we get from those pre-trained models to models which can respond to user intent um again um I hope this was covered somewhere in the class the general idea of pre-training and fine-tuning um but what you have probably seen thus far is that you pre-train on a lot of different language task uh on data but then you find on your specific task so you're taking the same decoder only models and you're fine
tuning to some task with very little amount of data the thing that is going to be different now is not that we're no longer fine tuning on a little amount of data we're going to fine tune on many many different tasks and we're going to just try to put them into a single usable um ux for users and this is where fine tuning or instruction fine tuning comes in cool um so again the recipe is not very very complicated here um we're going to collect a lot of examples of instruction and output Pairs and the
instructions are going to rrange over several task different forms um there's going to be question answering they're going to be summarization translation code reasoning and so on and we're going to collect a lot of examples uh related to all those tasks and the idea is like I mean we'll train on instruction and output pairs exactly with them and then we're going to evaluate on some unseen tasks as well so this is a general Paradigm of instruction fine tuning and again it's the same idea which we
explored in pre-training is that data plus scale is really important and these days like a mean you start off with like one task you're now extending it over thousands of thousands and thousands of tasks with like three million plus examples and this is generally like a broad range of tasks that you might see in instruction fine tuning data sets and yeah you might even think of like why are we calling it fine tuning anymore like it's almost starting to look like pre-training um but yeah we
can these are just terms um so so you can decide whatever you are comfortable with um so yeah we we get this like huge instruction data set we finder model the next question is like how do we evaluate these data sets um now I think you guys will see another lecture on evaluation so I don't want to like dive too deep into this but generally evaluation of these language models is an extremely tricky topic um there's a lot of biases that you need to deal with and a lot of this will be covered but some more
recent progess on this is like we are starting to curate these like really large benchmarks uh like mlu where the models are tested on a broad range of diverse knowledge and this is just one example which is and these are the topics that you will see and just to give some intuition of what the examples in these evaluation look like um under astronomy you might be asked what is true for type 1 a supernova or you might be asked some questions about biology and there's a huge host of tasks for
this and you can typically like these are multi- choice questions and you can ask the model to answer the question if they're instruction fine tuned already hopefully they can like simply answer the question but you can also uh Chain of Thought prompt these questions or few short promp these questions too and recently there's been a huge amount of progress uh on this Benchmark what people have observed is like more and more pre-training on more and more data and larger models is simply just like
climbing up these um the number on this so 90% is often seen as a benchmark Mark number that these model wanted to cross because it's roughly like human level knowledge or understanding and recently the Gemini models purply cross this number so yeah go ahead is isn't this like the entire sort of thing all over again right like imag at some point you're like okay maybe my methods are too like too fine tuned implicitly on on the image bi and isn't something like that happening here as
well uh um yes I think this is a tricky topic because a lot of the models often there's this idea about whether your test sets are leaking into your training data set and there's are huge concerns about that it's a perfectly valid question to ask how do we even evaluate this is why evaluation is actually very tricky but one General thing to be careful about is like at some point like it doesn't matter what your trained test is if the models are generally useful if their models are doing useful stuff like
does it matter like how if your test if you train on everything you care about and it does well on it like does it matter so yeah um again we still need better ways to evaluate the models um and to understand what methods are doing and how they're if they're improving the model or not but at some point like that those boundaries start to like be less important cool so massive progress on this Benchmark starting with gpd2 and like we're roughly at 90% which to the point where these benchmarks are
starting to become unclear if like improvements on these are actually meaningful or not um in fact like most of the times when the models are wrong like you might often find that the question itself was unclear or ambiguous so all evaluation benchmarks have a certain limited utility to them so yeah um going to go over like another evaluation example of how this recipe like changes things so T5 models were instruction fine tuned on a huge number of tasks and another Trend to or which I think will be the theme across
this lecture is that as your models become larger as they're trained on more data they become more and more responsive to your task information as well so what you will observe here is like as the number of parameters ex increase we have like T5 small FL T5 small and we go up to 11 billion parameters where where we have T5 XXL you'll see that the Improvement actually improves like going from a pre into an instruction model the instruction model is all the more better at following instructions so the difference is plus
6.1 and goes to plus 26.6 as the models become larger so this is another very encouraging Trend that you probably should train on a lot of data with a lot of compute and you know pre-training just keeps on giving so yeah um you I hope you guys get a chance to like play with a lot of these models I I think you already hopefully are uh but yeah before instruction fine tuning something when you're asked a question related to disambiguation QA um you get something like this and it doesn't actually follow the let's think
by step byep instruction very clearly but after instruction fine tuning it is able to answer the question here and yeah like more recently people have been like researching into like what the instruction tuning data set should look like there's a huge plora of instruction tuning data sets now available like this is just a representative diagram and there's a h open source Community developing around these as well um some high level lessons that we have learned from this is one lesson that I think might be
interesting is that we can actually use really large strong models to generate some of the instruction tuning data to train some of our smaller models so take your favorite model right now gbd4 maybe or maybe Claud or whatever and you can get it to answer some question s and generate instruction outut pairs for training your open source or smaller model and that actually is a very successful recipe so instead of getting a human to collect all the instruction output pairs or getting humans to generate the answers you can get bigger
models to generate the answers as well so that's number one thing that like has recently emerged another thing that are is being emerged or is like being discussed is how much data do we need I talked about millions of examples but like people have often found that if you have really high quality example you can get away with thousand examples as well so this is the paperless as more for alignment and this is still an active area of research on how like data scaling and instruction tuning affects
the final model performance and yeah crowdsourcing these models can be effective as well so there are very cool benchmarks that are emerging like open Assistant um yeah a lot of activity in the field and hopefully like a lot more progress as we go on yes um a question sort of in the spirit of this LMA paper uh doesn't like code or like I don't know like math word problems have this desired structure so like shouldn't we just like be training code models and doing like some English stuff and then just be like okay this is
the best reasoning we can get at some point right cuz like C code has the structure where where where like you're going sort of step by step and you're sort of thinking in in some way in like a so breaking down a concept into a smaller so you can consider like cod have like very high value tokens so maybe like just doing so I think there's again pre-training is a whole Dark Art that I am not completely familiar with but um code actually ends up being really useful in pre-training mixtures
and people do like up with code data quite a lot um similarly like I mean but it depends upon what the users are going to use the models for right um some people might use it for Cotes some people people might do for reasoning but that's not the only task we care about as you might see later on in the next step we'll discuss this as well is that people often use these models for Creative task they wanted to write a story uh they wanted to generate a movie script or so on and I don't know if like
necessarily training on reasoning only tasks would help with that so go ahead yeah would you explain like there there exists like some data distribution which is like high value for Creative tasks yes like I mean it seems like um a lot of PE people write about stories and everything on the internet all the time like which is not code and sometimes like there's this idea of hallucinations as well in this like field but you can often think like hey like creativity might be a byproduct of hallucinations
as well so I don't know what exact data would like lead to like more creative models but generally like there's a lot of data or a lot of stories that are written on the internet which allows the model to be creative yeah but I don't know if I have a specific answer to the question cool so we discussed instruction fine tuning um very simple and very straightforward there's like no complicated algorithms here just collect a lot of data and then you can start leveraging the performance at scale as
well like as models become better these models also become more easily specifiable and they become more responsive to task as well we're going to discuss some limitations and I think this is like really important to understand why we are going to optimize for human preferences cool so we talked a bit about this like instruction fine tuning is necessarily contingent on humans labeling the data now humans it's expensive to collect this data especially as the questions become more and more complex you want to answer
questions about what which may be at physics PhD level or things to that effect these things become increasingly expensive to collect so yeah this is maybe like perhaps obvious like collecting data pre-training does not require any specific data you scrape data of the web but for instruction fing you probably need to recruit some people to write down answer to your instructions so this can become very expensive very quickly but there's more limitations to this as well and we we just discussing this like
there are open-ended tasks related to creativity that don't really have like an exact correct answer to begin with so how do you generate the right answer to the kind of a question and yeah like language modeling inherently like penalizes all token level mistakes equally um this is what super fine supervised fine tuning does as well but often like not all mistakes are the same so this is an example where you're trying to do this prediction task Avatar is a fantasy TV show and perhaps you can see like I mean calling it an
adventure TV show is perhaps okay but calling it a musical May be like a much worse mistake but both these mistakes are penalized equally and I think one General aspect which is like more becoming increasingly relevant is that the humans that you might ask might not generate the right or the highest quality answer your models are becoming increasingly competitive and you want in some sense you're going to be limited by how high quality the answer um humans can generate but often I find that the
models are generating better and better answers so do we really want to keep relying on humans to write down the answers or do we want to like somehow go over that so these are the three problems we have talked about um with instruction fine tuning and we made a lot of progress with this but this is not how we got Char GPT um and one high level problem here is that even though when even when we are instruction fine tuning there is still a huge mismatch between the end goal is to optimize for human preferences generate an output
that a human might like and we're still doing prediction kind of tasks where we're predicting the next token but now in a more curated data set so that's still a bit of a mismatch going on here and it's not exactly what we want to do hopefully like I mean I'm going to take a second here to pause because this is important to understand the next section and if there's any questions feel free to ask so is this step uh still taken as a as a first step or we discard this it's a good question
so um I think this is still one of the more important steps that you take before taking the next step but people are trying to like remove the step Al together and jump directly to the next step so there's work emerging on that but yeah and this is still a very important step before we do the next step go ahead is PR two also present in pre-training uh and if so how how do you avoid that ver just by having a lot of data um yeah that's a great question uh there's two diff there's one difference
one major difference on pre-training um pre-training covers a lot more text so um just for context like I mean as we talked about it's pre-training is roughly 15 trillion tokens whereas like supervised instruction fine tuning might be somewhere on the order of millions to billions of tokens so it's like few orders of magnitude lower typically you'd only see one answer for a specific instruction but during pre-training you'll see multiple text and multiple completions for a same kind of a prompt
um now that's good because when you see multiple answers or completions during pre-training you sort of start to weigh different answers you start to put probability Mass on different kind of answers or completions but instruction fineing might force you to put and wait on only one answer does it okay but generally yeah like I mean this is a problem with both the stages you're right anything else cool so as this whole thing alludes to we're going to start to attempt to satisfy human preferences directly we're
no longer going to like try to like get humans to generate some data and try to do some kind of a token level prediction loss we're going to try to optimize for human preferences directly and that is uh the general field of rlf and that's the final step in typically getting a model like CH GPD so we talked about how collecting demonstration is expensive and there's still a broad mismatch between the LM objective and human preferences and now we're going to try and optimize for human preferences
directly so what ises optimizing for human preferences even mean um to like concretely establish that let's go through like a specific example in mind which is summarization um we want to train a model to be better at summarization and we want to satisfy human preferences so let's imagine that a human is able to prescribe a reward for a specific summary let's just pretend there is a reward function you and I can assign say like reward this is plus one this is minus one or something to that
effect okay um so in this specific case we have this input X which uh which is about an earthquake in San Francisco so this is news article that we want to summarize and let's pretend that we get these rewards and we want to optimize this so we we get one summary y1 which gives us an earthquake hit and so on and we assign a reward of 8.0 and another summary which gives us a reward of 1.2 generally speaking like the objective that we want to set up is something of the following form where we
want to take our language model P Theta which generates a completion y uh given an input X and we want to maximize the reward of rxy where X is the input and Y is the output summary in this specific task and maybe like just to like really concretely point out something here this is different from everything that we have done in one very specific way um we are sampling from the model itself in the bottom term if you see like we're using Y from P Theta everything we've seen so far the data is sampled from
some other source either during pre-training either in supervised fine tuning and we're maximizing the log likelihood of those tokens but now we're explicitly sampling from our model and optimizing potentially a non-differentiable objective cool so broadly the rlf pipeline looks something like this and first step is still instruction tuning something we have seen up until now where we take our pre-trained model we instruction tune on a large collection of tasks and we get some something which starts responding
to our desired intent or not but there are two more steps after this which are typically followed in creating something like instruct gbt the first step is estimating some kind of a reward model something which tells us given an instruction how much would a human like this answer or how much would a human hate this answer so we looked at something like this earlier but I didn't talk about how do we even get something like that that's the second step and then we take this reward model and we
optimize it through the optimiz ation that I suggested earlier so the maximizing the expected reward under your language model and we're going to go over a lot over in the second and third steps so the first question we want to answer is how do we even get like a reward model what about what humans are going to like like this is a very IL defined problem generally speaking so there's there's two problems here that we're going to address first is a human in the loop is expensive so let's
say like if I ask a model to like generate an answer and then I get a human to label with some kind of a score I'm doing this over millions of completions that is not very scalable I I don't want to sit around and label millions of examples so this is very easy like we're in a machine learning class so what are we going to do what we're going to do is we're going to train something which predicts what a human would like or what a human might not like and this is roughly um this is essentially a machine
learning problem where we take these Rewards scor scores and we try to train a reward model to predict given an input and output what the reward scores would look like simple simple machine learning regression style problem uh you might have seen this earlier cool now there's a bigger problem here and sorry go ahead one so do we use like I don't know like just embedding withier we use a real language model to do that um that's a good question generally like what we do is like we still typically need reward models where
they need to be able to understand the text really well so like bigger models and like they're typically initialized from the language model that you trained pre-trained as well so you typically start with the pre-trained language model and do some kind of prediction that we'll talk about and they'll give you a score how do you if you're doing that how do you separate X and Y how does the language model know which part it doesn't need to it can put the X and Y like it only sees X and Y as an input so
it doesn't need to T typically see it separated it's just going to predict a score at the end okay yeah the X and Y is more for notational convenience here because for us X and Y are different X is a question user asked and Y is something the model generated but you shove the whole thing into you shove the whole thing into yes cool now this is the bigger problem here and human judgments are very noisy we have talked about we want to assign a score to a completion this is something that's like extremely non-trivial to do
so if I give you a summary like this what score are you going to assign on a scale of 10 if you ask me on different days I'll give a different answer first of all but across humans itself this this number is not calibrated in any meaningful way so you could assign number of 4.1 6.6 and different humans would just simply assign different scores and there are ways to address this you can like calibrate humans you can give them a specific rubric you can like talk to them but it's a very complicated process and like still like
there's a lot of room for judgment which is not typically very nice for training a model like this if your labels can vary a lot it's just hard to predict so the way this is addressed is that instead of trying to predict the reward label directly you actually want to set up a problem in a slightly different way what is something much easier for humans to do is give them two answers or maybe many answers and tell them ask them which one is better so this is where the idea of asking humans
to rank answers comes in so if I give you a whole news article and ask you which summary is better you might be able to give me a ranking that oh this second summary is the worst but the first one is better and the third one is somewhere in the middle between those two so you get like a ranking which gives you um preference over summaries and hopefully like I mean you can see like the idea that is important here is that even when we have some kind of a consistent utility function even when I have it's much easier to compare
to something and know that which is better than this rather than ascribing it an arbitrary number on a scale and that's why the signal from something like this is a lot better now how do we get like we talked about we need like we get this kind of a preference data and now we need some kind of a reward score out of this and we shove in like our input we shove in a summary as well and we still need to get a score out of this but it's not clearly obvious to me like how do we take this data and convert it into that kind of
score um incomes are pretty good friends named Bradley Terry um and essentially like there's a lot of study in like many in economics and like psychology which basically tries to model how humans make decisions in specific case like this Brad lary model essentially says that a probability that a human chooses answer y1 over y two is based on the difference between the rewards that humans assign internally and then you take a sigmoid around it so if you have looked at binary classification before uh the
logic is simply the difference between the reward of some y1 minus Y2 or the difference between the winning completion and the losing completion is everybody with me till this point so the idea is that like if you have a data set where given y1 and Y2 where y1 is a winning completion and we have a winning completion YW and a losing completion y l um the winning completion should score higher than the losing completion go ahead sorry what is J is that a log or like sorry what what like what is the type of J like this number
here that we're getting as the expectation is it a log prop or what is it it's an log prop so it will be a scaler at the end sigmoid is so you're taking the let's say you have a reward model which gives a score R1 to like YW and R2 to y l you subtract that number you get another number you put it into sigmoid and you get a probability because sigmoid will convert a logit into probability and then you take a logarithm of that and you take the expectation of everything and you get this final number which
tells you how good your reward model is doing on the entire data set so like a good model of humans should behave like this a good model of humans would um score very low here so it would generally assign a higher reward to the winning completion and generally assign a lower reward to the losing completion cool the math is just beginning so um hold on to your seats um cool so now let's see where we are we have a pre-trained model p p d y given X and we got this like fancy reward model which tells us that hey how we have a
model of humans and it can tell us which instruction which answer they like and which in answer did not like now to do rlf generally like I mean we have discussed what this will look like uh we will copy our pre-train model or instruction tune model and we'll optimize the parameters for those models and I suggested that the param objective that we want to optimize is the expected reward when we sample completions from P Theta and we're going to optimize our learned reward model instead of like the
true reward model which humans would have typically assigned do you guys see any problem with this um is there something that's wrong here or like that might go wrong if we do something along these lines go for itel it might collapse yes okay um but generally at least from my intuition like if you're ever doing something and you have you're optimizing some learned metric I'd be very careful because typically our loss functions are very clearly defined but here my reward model is learned what when it's learned it
means it will have errors yes so it's going to be trained on some distribution it will generalize as well but it will have errors and when you're optimizing against a learn model it will tend to hack the reward model so it might exploit the reward model might erroneously assign a really high score to a really bad completion if your policy learns or if your language model learns to do that it will completely Hack That and start generating those gibberish completions so just as a general machine learning
tip as well if you're optimizing a learn metric be careful about what you're optimizing and make sure that it's actually reliable um and the way and this is obviously not desirable like I mean if you start optimizing this objective you're going to converse to gibberish language models very very quickly so typically what people do is that you want to add some kind of a penalty that like avoids it drifting too far from its initialization and why do we want to do that like if it cannot Drift from too
far from its initialization we know the initialization of the model is a decent language model and we know it is not necessarily satisfying this reward model too much and we also know that like the reward model is trained on a distrib ution of completions where the um initial model is so typically we when we talk about training this reward model we have trained on certain completions which are sampled from this initial distribution so we know the reward model will be somewhat reliable in that distribution so we're just going to
Simply add a penalty which tells us that you should not drift too far away from the initial distribution and just to go over this we want to maximize the objective where we have RMF which is our learned one model but we're going to add this term beta log ratio and the ratio is our the model we're optimizing P Theta and our initial model PP PT and what this says is that if we assign a much higher probability to certain completion as compared to our pre-train model you're going to add an
increasingly large penalty to it and simply you're paying a price for drifting too far from initial distribution if you guys have taken like machine learning this the expectation of this quantity can is exactly the cbak LI Li Divergence or k Divergence between P Theta and PPT so you're penalizing drifting between two distributions go forhead question shouldn't you also do this like add a penalty in the previous version where you had to find huning or is this only relevant for the RL HF
that's a good question so um I think people do add some kinds of regularization in fine tuning it's not nearly not as critical when you're doing this with RL like the incentive is to exploit this reward model as well as much as possible and we'll see examples where like the Learned reward predicts like it's doing really well but the true reward models are completely garbage so it's much more important in this optimization cool so now this assume does this course does not assume background on reinforcement
learning so we're not going to go into reinforce learning but I just want to give a very high level intuition about how this works and reinforcement learning is not typically just used for language model it's been applied to several uh domains of Interest game playing agents re um robotics developing chip designs and so on and the interest between like RL and model LMS it's also like dates back to roughly like 2016 as well but like it's been really successful recently and especially with
the success of rlf um the general idea is that we're going to use our model that we're optimizing to generate several completions for an instruction um we're going to compute the reward under our learned reward model and then we're going to simply try and like update the update our model to increase the probability on the high reward completions so when we sample a model we'll see completions of varing quality and we'll see some good completions good summaries for our task
some bad summaries for our task and we'll try to update our log probabilities in a way such that uh the reward for when you use a updated model you're typically in the higher reward region does the high level summary like make sense cool and rhf is incredibly successful I think this is a very good example of um this is the same summarization example and I think the key Point here is that the performance improves by increasing the model size for sure we have seen this in many different example what you
can actually see is that even very small models can outperform human completions if you train it with with rlf and this is exactly the result you see here the reference summaries are human generated and when you evaluate when you ask humans which ones they prefer they often prefer the model generated summary over the human generated summary and this is something you only observe with rlf even at small scales and again the same scaling phenomena still holds here bigger models do become more responsive
but are of itself is very impactful here cool the problem with rlf is that it's just incredibly complex like um I gave you a very high level summary that's like doesn't that there's whole courses on this for a reason um so it just and this image is not for you to understand it's just completely to intimidate you um so um you want to fit a value function to something there's you have to sample the model a lot it can be sensitive to a lot of hyperparameters so there's a lot
that goes on here and yeah um if you start implementing an rlf pipeline it can be very hard and this is the reason why like a lot of rlf was restricted to very very like high compute High resource places and it was not very accessible so what we're going to talk about and cover in this course is something called direct preference optimization which is a much simpler alternative to R LF and hopefully like that's much more accessible but but please bear with me there will be a lot of math on here but the end goal of the
math is to make come up with a very simple algorithm so hopefully like it's um and feel free to stop me and ask me questions you need in terms of like gbt 4 versus three like how much do the number of parameters in the base model help with like need to reduce the number of parameters or like in order sorry R the number of like examples from humans for RFS that work well yeah that's a really good question so generally speaking as the if you hold the data set size constant and simply increase the mod size it will improve
quite a lot sure but the nice thing is that you can reuse the data and you can keep adding data yeah uh as you keep like scaling models up so typically like nobody tries to like reduce the amount of data collection yeah right you just keep increasing both the things out cool so we talked about rlf and the current pipeline is some something like um we train a reward model on the comparison data that we have seen so far and we're going to optimize we're going to start with our pre-train our
instruction tune model and convert it into an rlf model using the reinforcement learning techniques now the really the key idea in direct preference optimization is what if we could just simply write a reward model in terms of our language model itself now to intuitively understand that like what is going on a language model is assigning probabilities to whatever is the most plausible completion next but those plausible completions might not be what we intended but you could restrict the probability simply to the completions
that a human might like and then the log probabilities of your model might represent something which the humans might like and not just some arbitrary completion on the internet so there is a direct correspondence between the log probability that a language model assigns and how much a human might like the answer they can have like a direct correspondence in them and this is not some arbitrary intuition that I'm trying to like come up with we will derive this mathematically so the general idea with
direct preference optimization is going to be we're going to write down reward model in terms of our language model and now that we can write our reward model in terms of our language model we can simply solve directly fit our reward model to the preference data we have and we don't need to do the RL Step at all so we started off with some preference data and we simply fit our reward model to it which directly optimiz as the language parameters and maybe at a high level why is this like even possible like we did
this like really cumbersome process with fitting a reward model and optimizing it but in the whole process the only external information that was being added to the system like was human labels labels on the preference data when we optimize a learned reward model there's no new information being added into the system so this is why something like this is even possible for quite a few years this was not obvious obvious but like as you will see like some of these results like start to make sense
so we're going to derive direct preference optimization I'll I'll be after I'll be here after the class as well if you have questions but I'll hopefully like this is clear so yes um we discussed that we wanted to solve this expected reward problem where we want to maximize the expected reward but we subtract this term which is the beta log ratio which essentially penalizes the distance between where our current model is and where we started off so we don't want to drift too far
away from our um from where we started now it turns out that this specific problem instead of doing like an iterative routine um there's actually a close form solution to this problem so the close form solution looks something like this um again if you have seen the boltzman distribution or something to that effect before this is very basically the same idea but the idea is this that we're going to take a pre-train distribution PPT y given X and we're going to rade the distribution by
the expected reward so if if if a completion has a very high reward it's going to have a higher probability mass and if it has a lower reward it's going to have a lower probability mass and it's determined by the expected reward and beta is a hyperparameter which essentially governs like what is the trade-off between the reward model and the constraint and as beta becomes lower and lower you're going to start paying more and more attention to the reward model so the probabilities look
something like this and there's this like really annoying term this ZX and the reason why it exists is that the numerator by itself is not normalized it's not a probability distribution so to construct like an actual probability distribution you have to normalize it and ZX is simply just this normalization so if we write ZX out is the sum of all y okay yeah and that's exactly like it's some overall wise for a given instruction and that's exactly why this is very pesky is like it's
intractable if I take an instruction and try to sum over every possible completion and not just like syntactically correct ones every single possible we have 50,000 tokens maybe even more and the completions can go arbitrary long so this space is completely intractable this quantity is not easy to approximate even um so the main point here is that you if you're given in a reward model you can actually there does exist at least a close form solution which tells us what the optimal policy will look
like or optimal language model will look like but if you do a little bit of algebra just move some terms around take a logarithm here or there I I promise this is not very complicated you can actually Express the reward model in terms of the language model itself and I think this term is reasonably intuitive as well uh what it says is that um a completion y hat has a high reward if the model my optimal policy assigns a higher probability to it relative to my initialized model and this is scal by
Beta so the beta log ratio is what we're looking at here and the partition function let's just ignore it for now but it's intractable but the beta log ratio is the key part here is everyone following along awesome okay so right now I'm talking about optimal policies but really like every policy is probably optimal for some kind of a reward right like this is mathematically true as well so the important bit here is that you can actually Express you take a current policy take your initialized model and
you can get some kind of a reward model out of it and this is the exact identity which leads to this so reward model can be expressed in terms of your language model baring the log partition term which we'll see what happens to it go for sorry I don't know how you got like why is it that we can swap because there is a thing that we're trying to optimize and how do p star turn into P yeah um for now like we're not optimizing any reward model okay all I'm saying is that if I take my current language model it
is it probably represents some kind of a reward model implicitly because of this relationship because this holds for every P star and every reward model what I'm saying is that like there if I plug in my current language model it also represents some kind of a reward model I'm not saying it's optimal okay but I want say because at the beginning uh PRL is PPT yes and so we just get that the reward is basically zero and so what what do we do initially it's zero but like we can optimize the
parameters okay okay yeah um yeah but that's a good observation that it's basically zero in the beginning but how do we start optimizing it I'll get to okay okay any other questions so the idea is that given the language model you have model such that that makes the language model op yes that's uh that's the next step yes uh but the key idea is that like my log my language model the probabilities already implicitly Define a reward model I think that's really the main point
here and this mathematical relationship is exact cool now like I mean I'm obviously ignoring like the elephant in the room here which is the partition function um it's not going to magically vanish away so like if this was just the beta log ratio that would be really nice I can compute all these quantities I know how to compute the log probability under my language model I know how to compute the log probability under my pre-train model and I can compute the reward score and I can optimize this but I don't know what
to do about my Lo log partition function this is where something fun happens so recall what the the reward modeling objective was uh when we started off like we started off with the friends Bradley Terry again and what we really wanted to optimize was the reward difference between the winning completion and the losing completion um and really like I mean that's all we care about we don't care about the exact reward itself what we care about is maximizing the difference between the the difference between
winning and losing completion and that's actually really key here because if you plug in the definition of of the RM Theta there what you'll observe is that the partition function actually just cancels out now why does it cancel out um the input is exactly the same the x is actually exactly the same in the difference so the partition function ZX will just cancel out like it's the same in both the terms so what you get is that the reward difference between the winning and losing completion is the
differences between the beta log ratio for the winning and losing completion you can plug in the terms you can work it out it's fairly simple so the partition function which was our like um which was something we could not address we could not compute actually just simply vanished away I'm so sorry Z doesn't appear in theary mod um but it appears here in this equation so how does plug in model um so we're going to take this equation uh the last line that you see and we're going to plug in in place of
RMF okay so um and in this the first loss equation oh I see got yeah so the first loss equation is the broadly ter loss model cool so this really is it like I mean the key observation is we could express our reward model in terms of language model and our problems with the partition function actually go away because we were optimizing the Brad lary model and um what you get is something like this is that um we're going to Express the loss function directly in terms of our language model parameters
Theta and we're going to be able to directly optimize on our data um without doing any RL steps or not and this is simply a binary classification problem so we're really just trying to classify whether an answer is good or bad and that's really what we're doing before I go on like people want to like absorb this in like I mean feel they're okay with it I don't get where they why good and why win and why lose come from are they human and or they good question um it's the same data set we started with in rlf
as well but the way the process works is that you take a set of instructions and get the model to generate some answers and then you get humans to label which answer they prefer so they're model generated uh typically they can be human generated as well but they're typically model generated and then you get some preference labels okay all you need is a label saying which is a better answer what do you lose here like you must be losing some information because of the lack of information about like
other you're canceling out your your your because of the lack of uh any information about the partition function yeah you are bound to lose information about like other possible completions which you would have taken into account in like standard rlf right um that's a really good question I don't think I'll be able to completely answer this question in time but like partition function is almost kind of a free variable so I think the problem here is that the reward model there think of
when you there's many reward models that satisfy this optimization so there's a free variable here that you can actually completely remove and that's what this optimization benefits from so think of it this way like if I assign something a reward of plus one and assign something a reward of minus one that's basically the same as saying as if it's a reward of plus 99 and it will give you the same loss right so um that scale doesn't that shift invariant in a ways is that like
isn't that somehow like not what you want though like like okay like if if you have if you're actually training a reward model right like 199 is like much you should pay much less attention to that as compared to like one right Zer or something what we're assuming is our choice model here is like if a human prefers something over the other like the probability is governed only by the difference between the rewards so that's an assumption that every rlf also makes and like DPO also makes now is that
assumption true not completely true but like it it holds to a fairly large degree but that's a good question yeah cool um I'll move on and rest of time um and really like I mean the goal of this plot is to like we actually get fairly performant models when we optimize things with DPO um we so in this plot I think the main thing that you should look at is po which is the typical rlf Pipeline and we are evaluating the models for summarization and we're comparing to human summaries and what we find is that DP and BP sort
of do similarly but you're really not losing much by just doing the DPO procedure instead of R LF and that's really compelling because DP is simply a classif app ation loss instead of like a whole reinforcement learning procedure so I want to quickly summarize um what we have seen thus far is that we want to optimize for human preferences so um and the way we do this is like instead of relying on uncalibrated scores we're getting comparison data and feedback on that and we use this ranking
data to either do something like rlf where we first fit a reward model and optimize using reinforcement learning um or we do something that like direct preference optimization we simply take the data set and do a classification loss on that um and yeah like there's trade offs in these algorithms like people when they have a lot of computational budget they typically maybe go for rlf or some routine like that but if you're really looking to get the bank for your buck like I mean you might want to go for DPO and if and
that's like probably going to work out of the box um it's a still an active area of research people are still trying to understand how to like best work with these algorithms so like I'm not making any strong claims here but like both of these algorithms are very effective DP is just much simpler to work with cool um so yeah like I mean let's see like we went through all this instruction tuning rlf what do we get um instruct GPD is the first model which sort of followed this pipeline it
defined this pipeline so we got models which did 30,000 or so tasks remember when we were doing like only one task and now we have scaled it up from th000 tasks to like 30,000 different task with many many different examples so that's like where we are with instruct GPT and it follows this pipeline that we just described in this case they're following a specific rlf pipeline where we explicitly fit a reward model and then do some kind of a reinforcement learning routine on top of it um and yeah like
the task collected from labelers looks something like this um I leave it to your imagination or you can look at the details but how we started off with this model was something like completions we see from G GPD 3 uh which you know explained the moon Ling to sixer and like it is not really following the instructions but instruct GPD will give you something which is Meaningful so it's inferring what a user wanted from the specific instruction and it's converting to a realistic answer that a
user might like and yeah these are just more examples of what an instruct GPD like model would do whereas your base model might not follow the instructions to your desired intentions and yeah like we went from instruct GPD to chart GPD and it was essentially this pipeline um the key difference here is that it is still doing the instruction tuning but it is more optimized for dialogue more optimized for interacting with users so the core algorithmic techniques that we discussed today are what give us CH GPD but you have to be
really careful about the kind of data you're training on and that's really the whole game um but this is the foundation for CH GPD and yeah it it follows the same pipeline as well and you might look at you might interact with ch gbd I'm sure you all have interacted with it some form or not but like this is an example of what a CH gbd interaction might look like um you want to make a gen Z so like I mean you can you know the idea here is that it's like very good at responding to instructions and intent this is not
something that we could like even fuse shot in very easily uh these are kind of instructions are hard to come examples for but like this is probably not something to trained on either but it's able to like infer the intent and generalize very very nicely and that's something I find personally very remarkable cool and there's been a lot of progress on the open source front as well so like DPO is much simpler and much more efficient and essentially all the open source models these days are
using DPO so this is a leaderboard that is maintained by hugging hugging face a so like I mean N9 out of 10 more models here are trained with DPO so that's been something that's been enabled the open source Community to instruction tune their model betters as well and same is being used in many production models now as well mistol is using DPO llama 3 used DPO so these are very very strong models which are nearly gp4 level and they're also like starting to use um these algorithms as well and something that's
very cool cool to see is like like we went through all this like optimization and like I mean math and stuff but what is really fundamentally changing in the behavior and I think this is a really good example is that if you simply ask an instruction for and ask for an sft output from an instruction tune model you'll get something like this but when you RL of the model you actually get a lot more details in your answer and they'll probably organize the answers a little better and there's something that
they maybe humans prefer that's why it's an property that is emerging in these model but it's something that's a very clear difference between simply instruction tude models and some models which are rft so yeah um we discuss like this whole rlf routine where we are directly modeling the preferences and we are generalizing Beyond label data um and we also discussed RL can be very tricky to um correctly Implement though DPO sort of implements this or like avoid some of these issue and we briefly also touched
upon the idea of reward model and reward hacking um and when you're optimizing for learned reward models you will often see this example is that there's a way for it to just simply crash into um the object some keep repe repetitively crashing the board to get more and more points that wasn't the goal of this game so um this is a very common example that is shown for reward hacking if you do not specify Rewards well the models can like learn weird behaviors which are not your desired intent and there's
something a lot of people worry about as well um part of the reason is reinforcement learning is a very strong optimization algorithm it's at the heart of alpha go Alpha zero uh which like results in superhuman models so you have to be careful about how you specify things and the other thing is like even optimizing for human preferences is often not the right thing because humans are not do not always like things which are in their best interest so something that emerges is that they like authoritative and helpful answers but
they often like don't necessarily like truthful answers so one property that happens is like is that they'll prefer authoritativeness more than correctness which is maybe like not something nice please go ahead on those lines I'm curious if maybe like chbt being so like now widely used by the public will maybe change the like how people were like made the rewards because I at least feel like now when I go to chat I TP something it gives me five like detailed paragraphs of information sometimes I'm just annoyed
by that that's not what I wanted but maybe in the original reward function in the original people actually pref that and nower it less yeah um that's a great point because like as these models like integrate more and more into our system they're going to collect more and more data and they will like pick up on things maybe undesirable things as well um as far as I understand chbd is really cutting down on the verbosity which is like a huge issue that all of these models are trying to cut down on and
they are dealing with that um part of the reason why that emerges is that when you collect preference data at scale people are not necessarily reading the answers the turkers might just simply choose the longer answer and that's a property that actually goes into these models so but hopefully like these things will improve over time as they get more feedb and yeah hallucinations is not a problem that is going to go away with RL and we talked a bit about reward hacking as well um biases from
things and so on but hopefully like I mean what I want to conclude out is like we started with pre-trained models we we had these things which could predict text and we got chargy GPD and hopefully like it's a little more clear how we go from something like that to chat GPD and that's I'll end here thanks